so doc
introduced today as sixers head coach
um
he said he actually thought about taking
a break he said he thought about taking
a break but this was a job that he this
is awful he couldn't refuse it's a job
he could not pass up the tradition in
this roster which he called loaded
um talked about the fact that if being
simmons have won 65 of their games
together if you watch my teams i don't
get lost in what positions guys play my
teams have always been very good
offensively top five overall we scored
points
talked about uh getting reunited with
tobias harris
yeah i mean they said look the team's
loaded i had to take this gig so but you
still you didn't like when doc was
unemployed for all the three days
um you didn't like the fit for doc
you've had a little time to think about
it you still don't like this fit you
still don't like doc in this position
you know it's so interesting to hear him
talk about it
because i mean
and this is and this is what i'm trying
to stop myself from doing
because we're both big doc fans and
we've talked about this before on the
show
we're both uh big doc fans and he's such
an excellent communicator
that i'm thinking all right if doctors
if he sees this oh wait a minute am i
missing something
he said oh yeah we you know ben has
always created points
we're not gonna worry about that right
now and watching the film embiid this is
a dominant big man i can't wait to work
with him i can't work i can't wait to
work with shake milton i'm like okay
yeah shane
you know what i mean go ahead
that's what i'm saying the song's
playing in your head right now
he'll get you fired up
but i'm wondering look
he can be as fired up as he wants i can
i can understand why he's excited about
embiid i understand why he's excited
about simmons
but he can talk all he wants what are
they going to do without warfare how do
i get al horford off that roster
i saw a bleacher report article that
said he's too expensive to be bringing
off the bench well he might be too
expensive to be coming off the bench but
he's coming that's what you need to
beach
yeah because nobody who's going to trade
for al horford and say yeah we'll give
you uh
we'll give you a couple good players i
mean just like the way trades work in
the nba you got to have some salary
coming back so there's still some roster
issues my point is there are some roster
issues that doc as excited as he is as
enthused as he is as he sounded today
i don't i don't love the roster i love
those two players
and maybe him throwing tobias harris
throwing shake milton if you want that's
a lot of players they gotta they gotta
remix that team
look steve kerr to golden state doesn't
doesn't happen that often like i said
before if it was a perfect roster the
perfect situation it probably wouldn't
be a vacancy there right so
i think you hit it off the top man like
if he could get
he wasn't brought in
to change the roster
at least overnight they gave a five-year
deal for a reason it's like hey we're
gonna see if you could get the if you
can unlock this roster's potential if
you can get these guys to buy and
they're paying him whatever they're
paying him
to get these players to buy into their
roles in the buy-in want to buy into one
another all right
so they'll say if you can't get this
done in a year doc whatever you know
you're not it's not a one-and-done
you're not a lame duck guy we'll blow it
up after this year as best we can
whatever that ends up looking like
challenging though that may be for the
point she pointed out
but nah man what i love about it is
doc can get embiid and simmons and even
horford because of the credibility that
he brings
you know no disrespect to brett brown
but
i mean come on you know like you go from
brett brown to a doctor why not
but yeah exactly right you know it's
like no disrespect but here's a
disrespect there's no comparison that's
not even disrespectful talking about one
of the top five coaches in the league
and on the cusp of being a top 10
winningest coach in nba history so
there's a credibility that he brings in
he's going to get these guys attention
get them to play the way he wants
um he's got credibility in the community
and in the city an organization they
deserve each other man doc deserves to
coach a marquee team like the
philadelphia 76ers a marquee
organization the flagship franchise like
the philadelphia 76ers deserve a coach
like doc rivers i also love so i love i
hope elton brand was like he's going to
be big for us on and off the court this
is an organization
that for a while has lacked credibility
you know they have they've lacked
respectability yeah they've won some
games but let's just call it it's been a
clown show in many respects at various
points in the last several last few
years i also like our doc was like
people try to make the mistake of of
trying to be golden state or trying to
build a team to combat golden state it's
like no we're going to buy into who we
are
and we're going to commit to being who
we are and play to our strengths and our
talents as opposed to trying to be
somebody we're not so i just like
everything he had to say
no surprise typically everything doc
says comes off great but i really do
like the potential for this partnership
yeah he's excited i i can tell he's
excited i remember we were having a
conversation
a few days ago
and and i said to you because you know
a full disclosure i mean i i i i try to
talk to doc as much as i can you know
i'm a big doc fan so
when i told michael smith the doc's
excited about this thing and he didn't
go into detail it got my attention
though it wasn't one of those i'll just
take the job because it's available and
that was my favorite he was going to
take a break he was going gonna break
that doc wanted to
keep coaching
that you're in that space you're like
hey i'm a coach because he didn't expect
the clippers to move on from him you
know especially at the end of that
series they blow that series to the
nuggets and if it doesn't happen in day
one day one day two day three after that
series is over now you start thinking
about next year
and sometimes when you expect to be
doing a job
and it's just yanked away from you you
think i just i just need to work
i don't want to take a break right now
but it looks like
it's not just work for him that this is
a good situation and if you think about
it philadelphia shout out philadelphia
as a basketball town
not just in the pros but in college big
five big five everybody palestra so it
is a it is a great basketball city
and when the sixers
are good then i think the nba is better
i'd like to see like the nick when the
knicks are good the nba has better since
a long time since that's happened
but the knicks the celtics the lakers
the sixers it's just a lot more fun
following basketball
when those teams are on it and the
sixers haven't won it mike you know the
last time the sixers won the nba title
19 83
it's crazy i mean 83 for the six or 73
for the knicks so we're talking about
these foundational franchises
and they they could use uh they could
use makeovers and renovations
and so doc rivers will give you that
i know they're going to be excited the
city is going to be excited
the players will be excited playing for
them question is how far can they go in
an eastern conference that is also
loaded